hey guys what's up I just seen here and
you're watching vlog University now this
isn't a new episode this is a
continuation of the last episode where I
had you guys submit cute animal videos
to me and before we begin the show
look at how freakin cute this is yeah
that's right
that's a chinchilla sitting in a wine
glass oh hold on wait that's not good
enough you want to join Chile's in the
wine glass so since this week you guys
don't have a homework assignment cuz you
probably already did it I'm gonna give
you guys some extra credits I happen to
be judging a t-shirt design contest in
math canvas comm so head on over there
and check it out and design yourself a
t-shirt or some extra credit okay so
let's just cut to the chase I know you
guys are here to see some cute animals
so let's see some here's a talking cat
by Tara bright
them them yeah oh what's that you want
to hear a dog sing oh great cuz look
we've got one now no dog video would be
ever complete without a laser pointer
you guys are sick of kitties and puppies
no great cuz there's a gerbil on a
skateboard thank you a little grade
don't hop off baby don't hop up no no no
hot buff oh good girl
thank you guys so much for watching this
episode of log University and as always
be sure to subscribe so you know when I
launch a new video and check out the
rest of my youtube channels here I love
you guys see you later